as we head into our bajillionth week of
the pandemic
many things about our lives have changed
but i saw a commercial last night that
reminded me that
some things will never change take a
look in these uncertain times it seems
like the world is upside down
sheltering in place closed school social
distancing
how are we supposed to cope well just
know that even though most things have
changed
one thing remains the same
racism racism will always be here for
you
racism it's like a hug from an old
friend who's on fire
and right when you start worrying about
something new
your old friend racism says not right
now bud
there's a new racist event to let
totally consume you
you would think that with everything
else that's happening racism would have
slowed down
nope so take comfort in the fact that
some things never change
they just get stronger and stronger till
they kill you so while you may feel
lonely
you'll never be alone racism will always
be here
just all up in your [ __ ] your sleep
schedule might be different but
guess who's always there to greet you
when you wake up that's right
racism as americans try to figure out
the new normal
they're looking to their neighbors and
they're calling the police on them
and you may think that since covet hit
there have been more instances of racism
is that true of course not don't be
insane
what a dumb thing to think why has
everything got to be about race with you
sorry that's just me trying to gaslight
you you know how racism do
girl so whenever you feel down about the
coronavirus
just remember the nazis had some good
ideas hey
racism not even a pandemic can stop us
that was fun and true
[Applause]
you